[Música]
Sean bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
historia en France 24 Mi nombre es
Álvaro Cordero
este 17 de mayo se cumple el décimo
aniversario del fallecimiento de una de
las figuras más oscuras de la política
latinoamericana El dictador argentino
Jorge Rafael Videla este militar gobernó
de facto su país entre 1976 y 1981
gracias a un golpe de estado contra la
democracia Argentina un período en el
que se estima que ocurrieron la mayoría
de las miles de torturas y 30.000
desapariciones que ocurrieron durante la
dictadura militar la toma de poder de
Videla se dio el 24 de marzo de 1976 en
un momento de especial convulsión en la
política Argentina para ese entonces
hacía menos de dos años que Juan Domingo
perón había fallecido y su esposa María
Estela Martínez conocida como isabelita
era quien estaba a cargo una figura que
no gustaba entre la plana mayor militar
y que bajo la excusa de restaurar el
orden fue de puesta de su cargo
con el inicio del mandato de Videla
comenzó la represión sistemática con el
pretexto de restablecer la paz social su
objetivo eran las guerrillas comunistas
establecidas en el norte del país sin
embargo la persecución se extendió A
militantes izquierdistas a peronistas e
incluso a personas alejadas de la
política que tuvieron la desgracia de
aparecer en alguna lista de objetivos
por error
el método más utilizado era el de la
detención arbitraria y posterior tortura
en centros militares estas vejaciones
intentaron ser ocultadas por el régimen
pero tras la caída de la dictadura en
1983 se demostró que no eran casos
aislados y como podemos ver en este mapa
estaban repartidos por todo el
territorio argentino y ejercían una
represión sistemática en todas las
regiones de Argentina a la vez
estos métodos llevaban al extremo el
dolor y el sufrimiento del ser humano y
tras ellos en algunos de los casos estas
torturas eran seguidas con el asesinato
de los opositores a la Dictadura
Argentina estas muertes se daban bajo el
mayor secretismo después de ser
torturadas algunas de estas personas
eran sedadas y arrojadas desde un avión
al río de la plata se estima Que en
total hay 30.000 personas desaparecidas
por esta causa cifras impactantes que
hicieron que durante la dictadura miles
de mujeres decidieran manifestarse de
forma pacífica en Buenos Aires para
exigir respuestas sobre el paradero de
sus hijos ellas fueron conocidas como
las madres de mayo y se convirtieron en
símbolo de la resistencia ante la
dictadura la actitud del régimen sin
embargo era de éxito por sus acciones
terminar con la corrupción imperante
restablecer una presencia activa en el
exterior
dinamizar nuestra economía y restaurar
la disciplina social
constituyeron objetivos prioritarios del
reordenamiento básico que el país
anhelaba
Hoy podemos decir que estos objetivos se
están alcanzando Gracias el esfuerzo
mancomunado de todos aquellos que
interpretaron el sentido patriótico de
la convocatoria formulada por las
fuerzas armadas pero esos objetivos que
nombraba Videla nunca se cumplieron la
economía durante la dictadura en
Argentina sufrió de forma notable y fue
causa de inestabilidad dentro del mismo
estamento militar además Videla casi
lleva a la guerra Argentina contra la
dictadura de Chile de Augusto pinochet
por la disputa Perdida de varias islas
en el Canal del beagle en la Patagonia
un enfrentamiento que solo pudo ser
evitado por el papa Juan Pablo II pero
que elevaría las tensiones con el país
vecino Lo cierto es que este tipo de
aspiraciones expansionistas eran la vía
para encontrar cierto apoyo Popular en
torno a una especie de cohesión
patriótica y nacionalista pero a la
larga terminarían costando caras a la
Dictadura tras Videla viola y galtieri
llegaron al poder hasta que en 1982 se
produciría la guerra de las malvinas
contra Reino Unido un desastre sin
paliativos que terminaría con el
directorio militar y traería de vuelta a
la democracia
esta restitución democrática trajo
consecuencias para algunos líderes de la
plana mayor de la dictadura como masera
viola y especialmente para Jorge Rafael
Videla quien fue considerado líder de la
insurrección de 1976 y promotor de los
asesinatos a opositores recibiendo una
condena de cadena perpetua en los
juicios del año 1985 sin embargo Videla
pasaría tan solo cinco años en prisión
debido a los indultos promulgados por el
expresidente Carlos menem en 1990 desde
ese momento él es dictador atravesó un
período en el que estuvo varias veces en
prisión por periodos cortos y pasó el
resto de los años en prisión
domiciliaria
la llegada al poder del kirchnerismo y
las peticiones de extradición de
Alemania por el asesinato de dos de sus
ciudadanos cercaron al exdizador en los
últimos años los indultos que recibió en
el gobierno menem fueron anulados y
volvió a prisión en 2008 por crímenes de
lesa humanidad y múltiples acusaciones
de asesinato y terrorismo de estado algo
que le valió la cadena perpetua Jorge
Rafael Videla murió en el penal Marcos
de paz el 17 de mayo de 2013 a los 87
años sin pedir perdón a las víctimas ni
arrepentirse de hecho consideró como
necesarias todas sus acciones con esto
concluimos si quieren conocer más
historias sigan conectados a France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]